[Music]
I'm super excited to be here with you my
name is PR I'm a software engineer
working at Google on kubernetes project
and Google container engine product from
its early days I'd like to show you how
you can easily monitor Auto scale and
troubleshoot your applications running
on gke a number of useful tools are a
part of the kubernetes itself but to
have a full-blown monitoring solution we
need more so I invited my colleague
deepak to join us today
Deepak please introduce yourself
absolutely Peter thank you so I am my
name is Deepak I am a product manager in
the Google cloud platform team
specifically I work on a Google stack
driver which is our DevOps tool and I'm
really excited to be here to talk to you
about what's available for monitoring
and logging and for identifying issues
in your application in troubleshooting
GCP native open source as well as
third-party commercial solutions so
we're excited to be here thank you Thank
You Deepak so I'd like to tell you a
story of a team this could be your team
the team work really hard to build a
product and it's time for its launch
they're chosen to run the product on gke
which is a great choice and during the
next hour you will see why by let's
start with a very quick recap so Todd is
the smallest unit of deployment in
kubernetes a pod consists of one or more
containers that will be scheduled
atomically the containers is the
containers in a pod can share an IP
address localhost networking and
inter-process communication deployment
is a kubernetes abstraction which helps
you to manage your application it's it
offers straightforward deployment
advanced updates including crawling up
the
and self-healing mechanism note is a
machine with containers run when using
kubernetes you shouldn't care about its
its kubernetes manages your containers
other than machines this can be either a
virtual machine in a cloud environment
or physical machine when you run on Prem
and cube Kotwal is a common light client
tool which allows you to perform all
operations on kubernetes cluster like
managing your pods so let's get back to
our team the code is written the initial
version of the project is ready it's
high time to introduce it to the world
so let's go to render application we
will use cube Castle run command the
only mandatory parameters are the
deployment man deployment name we just
burn up in our case and contain your
image to run we also specify optional
parameters here CPU requests one core
which will go big guaranteed amount of
resources for the pod this will also
help scheduler to make optimal decision
while choosing a note for our pot to run
this is required for horizontal pod out
of Skylar and I will explain the reason
later expose flag will end up with the
service being available externally via a
public API add IP IP address in GAE this
means that Google cloud load balancer is
created underneath part is the default
HTTP port okay so the deployment was
successfully created and exposed
externally
which means that our app will be
available in the Internet how can we
access our application we need to know
details how about the created service
this can be done with cube cuddle debt
service comment we can see some
information about service bar up the
most interesting for us
is external IP address we can see it
here the application is publicly
available we have some users and they
are happy that's easy we have more and
more users the team is happy the
management is happy everyone is happy
but one day something bad has happened
users started claiming that our service
doesn't work the team has to investigate
the problem as soon as possible ok so
let's do it the first of his idea which
comes to our mind is to check
application logs we can do it with cube
catalogs command the command allows you
to get most recent logs from a
containers STD air and STD out in our
case we can see that not every single
HTTP request succeeded the application
was not able to handle some of them so
the hypothesis is that we have some
performance issues to confirm that will
check research usage of the application
we can use cube Ketil top comment which
can display pot and node level resources
indeed the CP uses the describe as you
may remember we requested 1000
milliliters for to be available for the
pot so this means that CPU is saturated
in such situation kubernetes will try to
the pot the diagnose is clear we just
need more resources we can either
request more resources for the pot or
create yet another instance of the
application the second option is better
for us since this will also provide more
ability for example when a node where
one instance of applications running
goes down we will still have another
instance running on healthy nodes in
kubernetes we can easily add new
instances of the application by using
cube cuddle scale command we
need to specify the deployment my name
and target number of replicas the
instance will be automatically detected
by the load balancer and the traffic
will be sender we may want to check the
status of our application you can see
that we have two instances and both are
available so problem solved
the team is happy is happy they were
able to resolve the problem but Suzanne
the lead engineer is wondering whether
they need to scale the application
manually all the time so of course not
to decrease operational overhead
kubernetes offer a few auto scaling
features which basically are designed to
handle traffic fluctuations one of them
is horizontal product scalar which is
which is which is an answer for the
problem we just resolved let me explain
how does it work so the idea behind it's
fairly simple there is a kubernetes
controller which observes the
application and when it notices more
users of the application it will add
more instances in order to handle
traffic spike of course it also supports
scaling down where less users mean just
less spots scanning down helps us to
save computer resources horizontal pod
outer scaler
also known as a PA hazard for other
capabilities it it works in the way that
it periodically adjust the number of
application replicas upon demand it
ensures that average CPU utilization of
the application pods meets the target
value HP a works with indefinite minimum
and maximum boundaries and it supports a
number of kubernetes abstractions which
have ability to be resized including
replicas set and deployment okay how to
use how to use cube CTL out Auto scale
how to use horizontal pod outer scalar
we can set up it we can set up scanning
our deployment by using cube cattle Auto
scale comment we specified the
deployment to be scaled which is in our
case bar up minimum and maximum number
of replicas which is between one and ten
in the target CPU utilization to 70% as
you may remember we said CPU request to
1,000 min occurs HPL will try to keep
average CPU utilization of our
deployment around 70% this means that
when instances of our application use
more than 700 minicars
of CPU by average the controller will
scale the size of the deployment up in
the same way that we did it manually it
will prevent from the situation when a
pod will be saturated will saturate all
available spew and here is some rumors
from the kubernetes community the
community works currently on introducing
chemo tomorrow auto-scaling features the
first feature is ability to scan
application based on signals from inside
of it
like number of HTTP requests or average
request latency this is important when
research consumption of deployment
doesn't translate one to one to a
necessity of scaling another features
that kubernetes community is working on
is vertical pod autoscaler
which instead of tuning number of
replicas will be able to adjust resource
requirements of the application this is
important when application doesn't scale
horizontally once the feature are
available in open source version of
common kubernetes they will be of course
available in g/km okay so we saw
resolved the problem and we ultimate
ultimate eyes the process so we can feel
safe everyone is happy again but again
something bad has happened
let's open the panic room our
application was supposed to be outer
scaled let's check its status we can see
indeed it was scaled up to ten instances
but not only six of them are available
we can learn more about the application
by using cube cattle describe command
the output of the comment is usually a
huge blob of various kinds of
informations you can see only a piece of
them and what is most interesting for us
is the event section there we can see
that our that our pot failed to be
scheduled the message says insufficient
CPU which means that on any note there
is not enough free resources to fulfill
the requirements of the pot we have two
options we can either free up some
resources by deleting either unneeded or
lower priority pots or we can just add
more resources to our cluster we live in
a cloud world so of course they there is
no need to call our technician or let's
say order new servers we can just go to
google cloud and request more VMs but
can we automate this process ago at
Google we love automation so that's why
we introduced cluster autoscaler the
idea behind it is fairly simple cluster
autoscaler increases cluster size by
adding new nodes to be more precise
precisely here the nodes are VMs in
Google compute engine to the cluster
when an unscheduled pod appears in a
similar way when cluster autoscaler can
see unneeded nodes it it will remove
them as I mentioned the idea is simple
but not the implementation for example
scaling down is an a np-hard problem
the results a number of other hard
technical problems to solve there if you
are interested in in this area
please join kubernetes community the
work round out cluster autoscaler is
open to everyone and the cluster
autoscaler is currently in beta but
we've gotten a lot of good feedback from
users and have made significant
performance improvements that will be
coming with the 1.6 release of
kubernetes let me show you how scale-up
works so a new n scheduler will pod
appear in our cluster cluster autoscaler
will perform scheduling simulation to
check whether adding a new node will
help with scheduling this pod and in
case the answer is yes it will send a
request to Google cloud to create a new
VM which will be adopted by kubernetes
and become yet another node in the
cluster then scheduler will retry to
place the pot to the node 10 to the new
node scale down is slightly more
complicated so let's imagine that we
have a cluster with some pods running
running there the state of cluster
changes over time some pods are created
or deleted either manually or
automatically by horizontal product
scalar so we can see that apart from
node V was deleted and apart from node a
was deleted to yet another pot from node
a was deleted
so we ended up - in a state where the
cluster is pretty low utilized cluster
autoscaler observes the cluster state
all the time it will detect such
situation and perform simulation whether
it's possible to safely remove a node
what I mean by safely remove is all pods
from the node we will we'll find a spot
across other nodes in this case the
answer is yes Green pod from node C can
be rescheduled to note a
so the note C is empty now so it can be
safely removed so the benefits from
using cluster autoscaler art are clear
it allows to handle the service
popularity growth or just a temporary
traffic spice automatically it saves
money when the cluster is low utilized
so up until now we've been
troubleshooting with command-line but
some of us like Steve an engineer on
Susan's team are wondering if there is
another way it's 2007 tier we are
migrating to cloud world can you
immigrate old-fashioned command-line
tool to a new shiny UI no problem
kubernetes provides a great dashboard
which allows you to for example to do
all troubleshooting that we've done so
far and don't be afraid there is no plan
to sunset great old-fashioned cube
couple so you can see kubernetes
dashboard which offers view of your
events within the cluster you can see
logs there and matrix which is an area
where where kubernetes dashboard is
better than cubicle you can see some
visualization but only from a couple of
last minute so we've seen a lot of
useful tools so far such as real-time
monitoring real-time logging support for
basic troubleshooting but to have a
full-blown monitoring solution which is
sufficient for production use
we need more debug can tell you what
your options are so I totally agree with
theater on both accounts first one
totally logic a provides you native
inbuilt solution and tooling if you
look at how your application is
performing when you're identifying an
issue when it's happening and then
ability to set up out of scaling for
nodes and clusters and that's very very
useful but we also know that when you're
running in production environment when
you're running large number of nodes and
clusters that you actually sometimes
need you know powerful more powerful
tools and with more capability for
monitoring and logging and for running
your operations so what are these some
of these capabilities these capabilities
are things like historical monitoring
and logging so you might want to
actually not look at the things as
they're happening but you might want to
actually look at the data
what happened maybe it's Monday morning
and you might want to see something some
Fila that happened on Friday or maybe
something that happened there was some
spike a week ago and you wanted to see
like how this week looks compared to the
absolute historical data time series
data as well as dog-eater you want to
look at that start to compare things
also you want to do at once
troubleshooting so what you want to do
is you want to start looking at if
you're looking at a particular handler
or a particular machine or a particular
application you want to be able to do
some surface static sophisticated
queries so you can actually narrow down
a particular you know container or
particular pods or particular nodes that
you that you've been looking at our
application and see what was happening
there and then of course visualizations
so you know great tools available in GK
but furthermore visualization on
charting distribution metrics and things
like that that would be very very useful
and finally setting up alerting so when
you are looking at these metrics looking
at your log data you might want to
create metric ad hoc on that and then
set up alerts so that things errors and
exceptions or you know high latency
whenever those things happen you you get
paged or alerted on that so we'll talk
about what are the solutions and options
that are available and of course first
we will talk about Google's tag driver
so Google what is Google stock driver so
let us give you a little bit of
introduction about this here we have a
very brief summary of what stock driver
is in summary it's basically our GCP
native solution for monitoring and
logging and diagnostics so you can
keep running your application without
any worries and identify issues as
they're happening but I wanted to draw
your attention to the three words that I
have here in bold so the first one is
that it's an integrated solution so when
we started to envision
stackdriver we started to see that in
the marketplace and as well as when we
talk to customers they are using a
logging solution they're using a
monitoring solution they're using some
time solution and hooking things up with
some loading solutions then sometimes
they have a separate you know error
reporting solution and then Diagnostics
in other application level monitoring
they're using some something else but we
realized that really what you're trying
to do is it's a single workflow you had
an issue something happen you need to
figure out what happened go identify the
issue and is all right so we envisioned
this has one single product which has
all of these capabilities inside it one
single go to market one single package
second one is SAS so as you also heard
in the keynote today take an example of
Pokemon go they mentioned that they saw
traffic which was 50 times more than not
just their average but their best
estimation so what happens is of course
you you know as you dimension you can
auto scale and you can get more
computing power and you can get more
storage power and all that kind of good
stuff but also you have to realize that
you're monitoring and logging solutions
also need to scale so now you're sending
perhaps 50 times more log data perhaps
50 times more monitoring data that you
envisioned and if you are running your
own clusters you have to now start to
see what what you provisioned and you
know resize your clusters and and manage
that with with Google stack grammar you
have to do none of that it's completely
managed of course a solution and then
the last one is it's the hybrid solution
so of course we all live in a multi
cloud world and we also live in a world
where you know predominantly people's
companies still have loads and on-prem
so there are use cases where they want
you would want a single pane of glass so
we are not built only for GCP we are
built in Jesus
but we are not only for GCP we are built
for any cloud and right now we
officially support monitoring and
logging for AWS and you know in the
future we will expand that but right now
we already provide capabilities with
public API is that you can actually
bring in you know your your application
might be running anywhere and you can
bring in some of those signals from
anywhere from any cloud or even on Prem
so that's really sort of the vision of
stackdriver
and how we're thinking about that so
this again talks very briefly about
things that I mentioned which is the
first point around integrated so within
the Stagner package you'll see a
monitoring solution logging solution
monitoring to bring in all the you know
time series metric data and then
visualizing them setting up alerts
logging data to bring in free from high
volume log data and then debugging if
you're hosting your code on GCP you can
actually hook that up so you can
actually see when errors are happening
exceptions are happening you can go to
as the line of the code that is actually
triggering that and you can debug it and
then traces where you know you want to
get full stack trace you can go to
tracing and then error reporting
proactively identify his exceptions and
errors happening in your application and
gives you a visibility into that without
you hooking anything up so again great
out-of-the-box solution there so some
little all of that is stackdriver be a
building is in a very integrated way in
terms of different signals like so what
is really happening so like I mentioned
we are building truly for a hybrid world
so you might be actually on any cloud
service and you can even envision like
not a not a cloud environment but you
can we support that
like I mentioned AWS GCP officially
supported and then you might be running
any operating system we support all the
key operating systems today and then you
would be running you know so your VMs
and servers would be running that and
then finally your application so all of
these are generating a large amount of
data which come in form of as I was
mentioning log metrics error traces and
events and we can take all of that and
provide a single way
for you to analyze that get notification
on on that and visualize the data so
let's talk about a little bit of detail
of gk monitoring and logging
capabilities so for example here in very
brief you will see you know monitoring
when we talk about again time series
data you are used to seeing these kind
of charts and dashboards whatever
solution you use and that's what we're
talking about in monitoring and then
logging you basically have all the log
data it's like a time stamp structured
with like a text payload coming in and
you might want to do more queries on
that data in real time and look through
what is really happening and slice and
dice the data and then perhaps actually
use the log data to create more metrics
that feed into onto the metric side so
that's really a high level what we
provide for G K now let's let's go into
a little bit of more detail so at a high
level the way we think about or I think
about it is you know divided here into
four high level steps one is data
ingestion you really care about how do I
get my data into stackdriver whether I'm
running GK or something else and then
how do I manage that data right how can
what what are kind of tools that are
available to me for management and what
hierarchies do you support so I can
define a cluster perhaps and then and
then see data that way and then what's
happening with visualization what are
the capabilities available to me there
how do I actually see this and then
finally this is really important because
we are building GCP in a very open way
similarly we're building G gain in a
very open way and then we're building
Google stock in a very open way so it's
not just about providing the product but
also providing you the data service so
if you did not want to use Google
stackdriver
but want to take all of the data out you
have that capability as well so let's
talk about that first piece here data
ingestion so today any log that you have
system log audit log or application log
would come in by default into
stackdriver
from gka through STD air and city STD
out now that's not the best solution so
I'll talk to you about
map and how we are going to enhance that
solution but today that path is
available for you to bring data into
stackdriver by default the other thing
that's you know you're interested in is
in metric side and so hipster and see
advisor already send system level
metrics again by default to stripe
drivers so you would be able to see that
at the node level then we have public
API is available both for custom metrics
as well as for logs so you can write any
metric from your application user client
libraries both for the metrics again and
for logs or and send any custom log that
you might have so that's really the
capability that's available for GK in
terms of what you can bring in to stock
driver and how you can bring that in now
as I mentioned we'll talk about a little
bit touch upon a little bit on the road
map and what's coming but what you will
see there is what we are missing today
is application level metric right so
it's not very easy today do have a
package solution that comes that brings
all of that in so we'll talk about that
but let's talk about sort of management
and higher hierarchy so the way stack
driver is set up is that you have a
concept of stack member accounts and you
can keep multiple projects that you
might be running on the cloud within
that stack driver account and you can
see the metrics from those multiple
projects in a single view so you can
create a single chart for example or a
single dashboard where you're seeing
signals from all of that in in one place
so you might have multiple clusters that
you might be running some may be the one
running front end running back in in
different projects but you can visualize
them together so that's very useful and
again within the projects you have
concept of groups so within a project
you might be running multiple clusters
but if you want to define a a group
based off of nodes you can do that and
you can for example again some some
stuff is running maybe on staging versus
versus prod and you can you know
identify that and create groups and then
see the metrics only at that level so
you have that capability charts and
dashboard so you can again visualize all
this data both the log data that's
coming in and then create log based
metrics
visualize that as well as the system
metrics that we talked about is coming
in you can visualize or any custom
metrics that you bringing in you can
create your custom dashboards and then
you can set up a learning on that and
then data liberation touching upon that
quickly you have the real API is both
for monitoring as well as for logging so
you have metric data and as well as log
data that you can use real API so take
the data out but you also have for logs
because we know that log logging data
sometimes when you're taking it and
transferring it you need a more robust
pipeline to be able to do that and we
provide logs export to bigquery GCS and
pops up again at no charge at this is
free of charge for all the GK log data
that's coming in so which is also you
know gives you the power of other sort
of GCP products like bigquery so you can
take all your log data there and you can
do perhaps more analysis on your log
data there we store the log data by
default for 30 days in the but you could
perhaps even keep it for longer in
bigquery or you can take it for archival
into GCS and then we also send log data
again pretty much in real time to pops
up so you can actually stream the data
out and you can take that to a
third-party solution we have a we have
partnership with many commercial
solutions like Splunk and you can take
the data for example if you wanted to
all UGK logs or any of the logs there so
what's really coming up on the roadmap
so I think the two things that I think I
wanted to say one thing very
emphatically is that we are fully
committed to provide a best-in-class
solution for GK monitoring and logging
what's missing today is application
level monitoring from that and we are
working very hard on that we are working
on a sort of metadata solution to be
able to capture metadata agent to be
able to capture all the information as
well as provide you with application
level monitoring as well as logging in a
in a more agent-based fashion rather
than taking it from a CD or a CD out or
from the just just relying on heaps were
and C advisor so they will
an agent-based solution for both and
then you install that and you do not
worry about anything else
application system ordered level
information is all available to you and
then the second thing we're working on
is a curated dashboard for gk so if
you're running gk cluster GK nodes then
you would be able to see in stackdriver
if you fully curated dashboards so those
are the two things we're working on in
that order and you would see both of
those later part of this year so but
that's it
what are you know as this morning in
keynote election we talked about sort of
you know freedom to innovate but also
freedom to choose so again we're
building it in a way where you are not
restricted to that if you wanted to
choose a third-party solution there are
many good open source solution
commercial solutions available out there
here are a few that we have worked with
that we have heard that customers liked
and you know so one is Prometheus it's
an open source toolkit as you're aware
that gets you application level metrics
it scrapes all of that from from from GK
and it's an open source solution and
provides you some you know light level
of - booting as well with braum - and
things like that so very good solution
similarly Cystic third-party monitoring
solution they are built natively for
container they you know they that's how
they came up they were built for
container monitoring so again a good
solution commercial solution and inner
log data log is a more generic
third-party monitoring solution but they
have really upped their game on the
container world as well so again a good
solution and a good option and then for
log data
Splunk again like I was mentioning we
have a a pub/sub API based integration
available already with Splunk so again
through one-click if you already have a
blunt running in your internal cluster
or Splunk cloud you're running that
one-click configuration you can send all
your log data to to a pub sub topic and
then I can its plunk and subscribe at
your account can subscribe to it we have
a well documented and validated solution
on that so those are the things that we
are excited about offering for GK
and recommending as well as you know
what is available within stock grabber
for you to look at and what what we're
building we're really really excited
about that and I'll give give back to
Peter
so basically coming back to our team
they are happy because they can focus on
building great product rather than you
know being involved in all the depth in
all those def of stuff kubernetes and
ji-ae offers them built-in simple
monitoring and logging solution
it offers tools for troubleshooting
it offers various kinds of auto scaling
above cluster and pod level and more
features around autoscaler auto scaling
coming soon ji-ae offers out-of-the-box
advanced instrumentation with stag
driver and of course you can use any
other monitoring solution it is possible
to integrate with with other monitoring
solution I would like to thank you very
much for for coming for attending this
session even if you are interested more
in Google container engine I can
recommend you the following sessions
especially the first the first one where
they'll we will there is customer
invited phillips hill who will show how
they use auto scaling in the production
environment thank you so much
[Music]
you